my advice to a young filmmaker is to  make a movie every week in super 8 or  high def  right every night  and every weekend shoot for two days and  work with actors work with a little 1000  watt lighting kit set it up set up your  shots get a tripod  shoot a little scene work with the  actors cut those scenes together and  then the next weekend  have worked on it with sound and looping  and put some music to it it can all be  done for nothing nowadays with the  computer and get a response and get a  response from the audience and see where  it's slow and where it doesn't work and  your ideas weren't being communicated  properly learn from that experience  sitting in with the crowd then go out  make another picture the next weekend  and just keep doing it  make films no matter what anybody says  and you'll be a filmmaker